we start with an unusual observation
there is a huge variance in how much we
feel we have to say for ourselves around
some people compared to around others
certain people make us feel boring
others do not we tend to evaluate people
on how interesting they are but we're
thereby liable to miss a more acute and
relevant issue how interesting does a
given person make us feel why in the
company of some people do our minds
quickly fill with stories while around
others we experience ourselves as blank
dull and close to inert why when some
people ask so what have you been up to
lately do we positively brim with a
multitude of topics whereas with others
faced with the very same question will
struggle to remember that we have ever
even
existed to explain the phenomen phenon
we have to credit our unconscious minds
with a faculty we might never have known
we possessed throughout our interactions
with people we are continually picking
up on small Clues as to how much our
interlocutor is understanding and
appreciating of what we're saying when
we mention a given issue how much do
their eyes light up how much can they
follow how much of our reality can this
person accept how much shocks them how
much can they take in their stride how
much of what is noted and complex in us
can they safely receive how much of our
reality would we need to hide from them
to spare them and therefore us an
alarmed or censorious
response from the answers to these
multiple data points we come without
typically even realizing we've done so
to a broad and active conclusion how
much of me this person is likely to get
and rather simply the more the answer is
a lot lot the more we will have to say
and the more the answer is not so much
the more a cautionary Instinct will form
inside us telling us to remain quiet
this simultaneously helps to explain how
someone gets to be a companion around
whom people feel they have a lot to say
they do this by opening many rooms in
their own minds or if you like by saying
a lot to themselves of course this is
far from simple many rooms of our minds
contain very frightening things indeed
areas of properly daunting loss pain
horror and Chaos which we can be
forgiven for never wanting to go
anywhere near yet a person will feel
interesting precisely to the extent that
they have become a brave and relaxed
Wanderer inside their own minds that
they have become familiar and one could
almost say at ease with things that are
sad dark agonizing and potentially
shameful
when they're at home with their own
anxiety grief strangeness and silliness
so by a beautiful principle of
reciprocity they will be at home with
ours as well where they have gone we can
follow because they have talked to
themselves we will be able and Keen to
talk to them what they have felt safe
exploring in themselves we will be able
to safely unpack around
them this gives us guidance as to how to
become a more interesting person for
others by becoming the best possible
Travelers inside ourselves we need to
open as many doors to our psyches as we
can for this will simultaneously
surreptitiously let out a signal to
others that we will be a safe recipient
for all of their smaller more private
less often mentioned observations and
feelings other people will have much to
say to us once we have had the courage
to say a lot to
ourselves